Bảo hiểm xác hội năm 2020, sẽ chính thức có hiệu lực từ ngày 1,5 năm 2020,
với nhiều điểm mới quan trọng nằm bởi giống dịn bác phụ và năng cao quyền lợi trong người lao động.
Một trong những lỗi dung đăng truyến là quy định người lao động làm việc không chính thức,
không mang tên hợp đồng lao động, nhưng có trả công và chữ sự quả lý.
Giám xác của một bên sự dụng lao động cũng phải tham gia vào hiểm xác hội bắt buộc.
Ngoài ra, người lao động làm việc không trọng thời gian,
có mức lượng bằng hoặc cao hơn nước lương tối thiệu làm cân cứ đám bảo hiểm xác hội bắt buộc.
Người hoạt động không chuyên trách ở thôn, tổ dân phố, chù hộ kinh ra, người quan lý xanh nghiệp,
thành viên hộ đồng quan trị và lực lượng dân quân thường chứ cũng thuộc dính này.
Lột cũng bởi giống quyền lợi trong người hoạt động không chuyên trách cấp xác,
từ ngày 1,5 năm 2020 sẽ được phường về đủ các chế độ bảo hiểm xác hội.
Bà ngồm ủng đau, thai sản và tên ảnh lao động,
thay vì chỉ được phường chế độ hiệu chỉ và tử tất như trước đây.
Tì lệ đám bảo hiểm xác hội bắt buộc bấm xữ quyền, người lao động mối phẩy năm tâm,
người xử dụng lao động đống 2,5 năm tâm trên cơ sở tỉ lương làm cân cứ đám bảo hiểm xác hội.
Chính sách này, nằm tăng dịnh báo phủ bảo hiểm xác hội,
nâng cao hội khoả chính sách án xin xác hội và bảo vệ người lao động trong bối cạnh thiệt trường lao động ngày càng linh hoạt.
Đà ra.